[Musique]
c'est au village corail à saint-gilles
que le département a organisé la journée
au féminin cette journée exceptionnelle
pour tous les agents féminine des
départements professionnels agents
administratives ont pu bénéficier d'un
moment convivial
ça fait plaisir voilà deux tentes pour
prendre soin de soi
essayez les ateliers maquillage
départ mais voilà les massages way
combler les collègues
voilà surtout ces recettes se retrouver
entre à gent féminine entre collègues
peut-être il faudrait augmenter encore
plus des ateliers parce que ces journées
connaissent un succès certain et du coup
les temps d'attentes aux ateliers sur un
petit peu si je pourrais mettre un petit
bémol en voilà mais sinon c'est super
bonne initiative
cette année plus d'une quinzaine
d'ateliers étaient proposées au
programme soins du visage maquillage
massage et réalisation de bouquets de
fleurs ça se passe très bien
là j'ai fait ma composition de fleurs
contente et merci en tant que président
j'ai pas encore eu le temps je reste là
dessus et après j'irai voir les autres
ce temps-là free mais celui-là me plaît
une journée qui s'inscrit dans le cadre
de la journée des droits de la femme
ceret milchior président du département
a rappelé tous les combats qui restent à
mener
parce que ces femmes le mérite bien
nous avons un personnel féminin qui fait
un travail extraordinaire qui fait un
travail dans le domaine du social bien
souvent donc des missions
particulièrement difficile à porter et
il est normal que la collectivité
départementale
à un moment donné remercie le personnel
féminin pour son engagement pour son
sens du service public et cette journée
elle est faite pour cela
c'est une façon de récompenser les
femmes qui travaillent au département
pouvoir leur engagement le rendez vous
est d'ores et déjà pris pour l'année
prochaine
[Musique]